a new report from inside failed former
president Donald Trump's Inner Circle
shows that Donald Trump is now furious
with Kanye West and is claiming that
West tried to F him this is going from
crazy to even crazier and it all relates
to this white supremacist dinner as it
is now being called think of that term
now being part of the the news cycle for
days Trump's white supremacist dinner
now the subject and triggering factor
for his ire against Kanye West as well
as Nick Fuentes and others article from
NBC News lays it out quite interestingly
the article is called the inside story
of Trump's explosive dinner with yea and
Nick Fuentes what was supposed to be a
private dinner ended up being a
political nightmare now I want to be
clear and make sure people know
some of the things that are in this
article which seems well enough Source
let's put it that way are being denied
by Nick Fuentes but I actually believe
that that doesn't mean that much because
when tests may not even be privy to some
of what is here the narrative is
compelling I encourage you to read it
and we're linking to it it's by Mark
Caputo and it says just two days before
Thanksgiving Trump was planning to have
a private uneventful dinner with an old
friend yay the rapper formerly known as
Kanye West they arranged to have dinner
Tuesday night at Mar-A-Lago after some
phone conversations but Trump may have
been walking into a trap Trump has said
he didn't know Fuentes the white
nationalist and anti-semite or his
background that West said hey he wants
to come in and have dinner with us as
well there is a damage control campaign
now being put together that the NBC news
article explains but the most
interesting part of this comes under
this section the master got trolled the
headline grabbing attention on his
guests and therefore the subsequent
Fallout were all but insured by Trump
before the dinner when he made a grand
entrance at 8 pm on November 22nd
understand that at Mar-A-Lago there's a
table reserved for Trump and his guests
it's in full view of everybody so it can
have all the Pomp and Circumstance that
a narcissist like Donald Trump would
want
so there was no question that everybody
was going to see who was there but it
ended up not being a happy photo op yay
criticized Trump for not doing enough to
help the Trump rioters he told Trump he
might run for president and that Trump
should be his running mate which
infuriated Trump reportedly who then
attacked Kim Kardashian yay's ex-wife
yea later put out a video saying Trump
is really impressed with Nick Fuentes
Fuentes says he praised Trump as my hero
and criticized DeSantis and then the
advisor that spoke to NBC characterizes
the entire thing as the master troll got
trolled Kanye punked Trump and there is
a section about Milo yiannopoulos who I
believe may have actually really been
the orchestrator of this entire thing
and the most interesting paragraph maybe
of the article
Trump fumed afterward that yea had
betrayed him by ambushing him quote he
tried to F me he's crazy he can't beat
me Trump said according to one Confidant
who then relayed the conversation to NBC
News Trump was totally blindsided The
Source said it was a setup
supposedly summoned Trump's orbit warned
him don't have dinner with Kanye who's
already Under Fire for anti-Semitism the
inclusion of Fuentes making it all the
more volatile so first of all none of
this is the picture of stability Kanye
is not stable Trump is certainly not
stable nobody involved in this thing is
even remotely stable now Nick Fuentes is
denying that this was overtly a setup
but the truth is that Fuentes may have
simply been a pawn in the setup rather
than a participant for all we know this
sort of thing has Milo yiannopoulos's
fingerprints all over it quite frankly
and as you know I've been in touch with
Milo over the years it's been years
since he agreed to come on the program
multiple times I've invited Milo to come
on he has rejected the offer he's
welcome to come on anytime and I would
love to talk to him about this but
there's a few different things that are
important to understand one seemingly
nothing is below the Office of the
President at this point in time okay
consider how much American politics has
changed in 2004 Democratic
um uh primary candidate for president
Howard Dean screamed about we're gonna
go to Iowa you know he made a noise he
screamed it ended his campaign
it seems so quaint at this point in time
where Trump is having Kanye West at
dinner and he's surprised that Kanye's
even crazier and then Kanye has a white
nationalist in tow and Milo yianopolis
is involved and they've they're having
this dinner in a public setting where
everybody can see so politics has
changed dramatically in the United
States that's for sure and by the way
imagine being Trump and ending up
surprise that Kanye is even crazier than
you are like it's sort of like a race to
the bottom here that's going on so who
set up whom it's not completely clear at
this point in time but what does seem
very clear
is that you know Trump never had a great
team around him his 2016 team wasn't a
great team they did end up getting him
elected when we have to give them credit
for that Trump's 2020 team was even
worse they failed to get him elected I
don't know who's around Trump at this
point in time for what is a very early
start to his 2024 campaign but either
it's a disastrous team or Trump simply
doesn't listen to them which would be
pretty on brand with what we've learned
about Donald Trump wacky wacky times and
I don't think these types of stories are
going to go away and we have to devote
just a couple of minutes to the
continued middle of the night rantings
from Donald Trump let's talk about that
momentarily good habits have to be
sustainable in order to become habits it
has to be something you'll actually do
and when it comes to nutrition some
people have hours to plan out every meal
their exact vitamin intake I'm not doing
any of that I don't have the time here's
what's sustainable for me I start my day
with just a single scoop of ag1 from
athletic greens it gives me the entire
day's worth of the 75 high quality
vitamins minerals and probiotics I want
from whole food sources it's just simple
it's just one scoop of ag1 I get all the
nutrients I want I don't have to do any
math use my protractor my TI-83 or take
a bunch of different capsules and pills
it's not some kind of wacky supplement
making a bunch of crazy claims you know
I would not promote something like that
ag1 is just a simple product it does
what it says it does it gives you the
daily nutrients and vitamins you likely
want vitamin A C E magnesium zinc
potassium in one simple scoop you keep
your body nourished you'll also get a
free year supply of vitamin D which I
take in the winter plus five free travel
packs at athleticgreens.com Pacman the
link is down below